is my mic on
yeah i'll do these safety
members members before we uh start the
actual meeting i'm going to do the
safety announcement please
so good evening and welcome to the
meeting um of the development committee
there are no planned fire drills
so if the alarm activates please leave
the building in an orderly fashion via
nearest fire exit
the two fire exits through the
partition doors are currently not in use
that's those ones over there
due to ongoing ongoing works therefore
fire exits are through the main doors of
the hall or the storeroom adjacent to
the stage please familiarize yourselves
just in case
daniel's doing his uh air hostess thank
you
the fire assembling point
is to the
roundabout stroke island in front of the
main entrance to the building please do
not delay your evacuation to collect any
belongings please do not return to the
building until given permission so to do
so by council staff
please note that the meeting will be
audio
recorded please switch off mobiles or
turn them to silence
toilets and hand washing
facilities are available in the fire
area
thank you members and members of public
can you stop yep right members when i
invite you to speak please ensure you
have one of the microphones in front of
you before speaking as microphones are
needed for the hearing loop
and for the audio recording
there are all they are these are all
switched on
and ready for you to speak so you do not
need to adjust them
make sure that the microphone is
directly in front of you before speaking
members voting will be done on a show of
hands in line with the constitution i
will ask for a show of hands
for and then against recommendations
those abstaining from voting will be
noted by officers
item
agenda item on apologies for absence
we've had apologies for absence for
receive from councillor agenese
councillor jack rahman and councillor
mrs christine mason are there any other
apologies please
substitute members our agenda item two
we've got councillor lisa newport for
councillor mrs christine mason
councillor mrs wilson for councillor
ayes is there any other substitutes nope
thank you
agenda item three non-member nom
members attending councillor mr newport
and sorry
councillor miss oh sorry i didn't see
you sorry councilman
across thank you
agenda item 4 minutes on the meeting
held on the 23rd of august 2022 are
these agreed members
thank you
there are also
minutes
in the pack
for the second of august just showing
the amendments that were required for
that meeting so
thank you
agenda item five
to receive declarations of interest
i have one i am actually i want to
declare a non-procurement interest for
item
eight because i am
i have acquaintance with the speaker
thank you
miss
councillor cross
would you um
officers would you like
counsellor across to actually come to
the mic so you could actually hear that
on the recording yes councillor cross
can you come to the microphone just so
you can say that so it can be recalled
it's like it's heard on the recording
thank you
yes thank you chairman um
i'd uh like to declare a non-pecuniary
interest for in relation to agenda item
9
which is a property adjacent to
17 brackendell
my property is on the corner of
brackendell
the address 15 louise road thank you
thank you very much council lacrosse
members
item six
um
21 strokes 0 6 7 3 4 rainbow zen beaches
road roarth
retention of one mobile home proposal
for additional mobile home for the use
by one romani gypsy family
there any visiting members that would
like to speak on this
uh we've got councillor
yes we have sorry councillor crips and
council stanley would you like to speak
obviously
oh sorry council
newport would you like to come
she needs to do the presentation
oh yeah
sorry
yeah yeah sorry i've just lost the plots
tonight i do apologize
i'm thinking this is this covered
injection i've had it's killing me
go on katie sorry i do apologize
can everyone hear me yeah yep great and
so the application site is located on
the northern side of beaches road
we've pulled up some aerial images
so
the application site is located to the
bottom of the screen you can see beaches
road on the south and then this is the
river crouch just to the north you can
go to the next image please
so we have the application site you can
see the existing
uh mobile home here the additional
mobile home that was brought onto the
site this is a menage and then this is
the access
so the site is adjacent to the
businesses drake trees and wildflower
traveling tea party which you just see
off the screen here
and the application site is located
towards the junction of beaches road and
chelmsford road where there is a higher
proportion of development then to the
east of the site where the street
becomes immediately more rural in
character by comprising open fields
which are absent of built form the
applicant has lived on the site
sorry i think i was talking into the mic
a bit as well
um
so the applicant has lived on the site
within the mobile home since temporary
permission was granted for the
agriculture occupancy in 2019 and in a
previous mobile home on the site since
2016. so the
mobile home here is the one that was
granted temporary permission
we
so we've got some site photos so in the
background of the photo you can see the
additional mobile home in the forefront
you see the
uh existing mobile home and a touring
caravan and then the managers here go to
the next one and then again that's just
a bit more zoomed in next monday
so this is the additional mobile home
that was brought onto the site this is a
stable block and then you see the corner
of the menage
next one thanks
and this is the existing mobile home and
touring caravan
and then again just another view is
there anymore oh and then this is from
the road so the site is just up here
where you can see this dense hedge next
one please
and then the mobile the additional
mobile home is sited behind here
and then you see the access in this
photo here and then the mobile home is
cited along this part of the road
plan information is sought for the
proposed use of land for the stationing
of two mobile homes to be used by the
applicant and his daughter as a romani
gypsy family the applicant and his
daughter have been considered to meet
the definition of gypsy and travellers
one of the mobile homes is existing and
would be retained
the application came before members at
the august committee where it was
deferred due to the concerns of the
impact of the sighting of the additional
mobile home along the southern boundary
upon the public realm and the daughter's
mental health the layout of the site has
subsequently been amended and a revised
site layout plan submitted showing the
positioning of the additional mobile
home along the eastern boundary
so you can see that the mobile home has
been amended to
sit here and the existing unit has been
also turned horizontally but
whether or not the applicant chooses to
do that i don't think is material to
this application is that we're granting
the use of the land as opposed to the
exact sighting apart from for this
mobile home unit here
so the applicant has confirmed that the
menage would be reduced in scale to
accommodate the sighting of the mobile
home it would be separated from the road
by a 1.8 meter grass verge a 3.9 metre
deep hedge and then would be set back a
further 9 metres from this hedge the
revised layout would result in the
mobile home being a less prominent
addition along the road and would no
longer be adjacent to the equestrian
buildings it is considered by officers
that the revised layout has overcome
members
concerns however condition has been
recommended requiring the additional
mobile home marked x on the plan to be
retained as shown on this layout plan
and that just secures that the layout
the mobile home cannot be moved around
the site so that it does actually
address members concerns
the principle of the development has
been discussed at the previous committee
whereby it was set out that while
substantial weight is given to the harm
to the greenbelt significant weight is
also attached to the need for gypsy and
traveller sites the lack of supply of
sites particularly the uncertainty in
bringing forward the only allocated site
the absence of local policy the lack of
available alternative accommodation and
the personal circumstances of the
applicant and his daughter
in this case it was a certain that there
are a number of matters which are
considered to weigh significantly in
favor of the application and this
conclusion would be consistent with the
outcome of recent appeal decisions
the cumulative weight of these very
special circumstances are considered to
clearly outweigh the substantial harm
arising from the inappropriate
development in the green bill
the revised sighting of the mobile home
would have no greater impact upon
adjoining neighbours as the nearest
residential dwelling is some 200 metres
away no neighbour comments have been
received in relation to disturbance to
amenity and is considered that the
proposal would not have a detrimental
impact upon this an existing an existing
access would be used to access the site
and raises no objection from the highway
authority
the additional mobile home would be
connected to an existing septic tank
which can be seen on the revised layout
plan
it's not quite clear the writing on the
screen but it's this bit here that you
can see
as this is existing officers have not
requested details of this the
application site is located within flood
zone 3 and as stated previously
development of this kind would not
usually be acceptable within the flood
zone however there is an existing
permission on the site which has
accepted the flood risk due to the
council's emergency planner stating that
this could be managed through a flood
response plan as the development is for
one additional mobile home within the
same family unit it is not considered
that there is a greater material flood
risk on site nevertheless officers have
included an additional condition
requiring an updated blood response plan
based on time which has passed since the
original flood response plan was agreed
and this has been included since the
last committee so you won't have seen it
previously but it was included on the on
the revised report
finally the hedgerow along the southern
boundary is considered to offer a high
degree of amenity and screening of the
site from the public room and should be
retained and a condition has been
imposed seeking retention of this the
application is recommended for approval
chairman subject to the conditions set
out in the updated offices report
thank you thank you sorry i missed you
first of all that's okay i do apologize
councilman a newport uh would you like
to sleep on this you have five minutes
and i'll give you an indication when
there's one minute to go thank you thank
you chairman
members um before this meeting convened
tonight
i handed all of you a um spatial
analysis of uh
gypsy and traveller sites in the
district and the numbers that we
currently
number of pitches that we currently have
which totals 38.
officers make much of the facts to um
the committee that
we don't have enough pitches and being
brought forward but there are 38.
um they have actually alluded to
a mention in the report also
that the leader of this council
is um actively seeking a compulsory
purchase order to bring forward the
allocated site at michelin's farm
which will bring a further 15
pitches
to
our district
so the numbers are in fact
quite significant as the core strategy
does state that there will be 15 pitches
policy
gb1 says the council will allocate the
minimum amount of green belts but here
we are again
looking at more development on the green
belt
i
hope the committee will take this into
account when they're making the decision
tonight
and move for refusal for this
application thank you
thank you
we now have the wall councillors uh
cancer crips councillor stanley
uh council preps
officers
use the word waiting quite consistently
through their reports albeit not
measured in any way
but it does imply large small minor
inside
there's in this particular case and in
similar cases to this i've sat through
since my short time here
much is made and heavy weight is given
to the
problems with alternate pitches
and non-provisioned by this council of
the
local planning
allocation that they gave
i don't see any waiting
against the information that's come
available this week from ivonta
where we've already got 38 pitches
across
the district
and incidentally 22 of them are in
aurora which is where this particular
application is as well
so
with only waiting on the one hand and
not on the other hand i'm not moved to
keep on supporting
greenfield
development
when we look to be over our quota
already
and with the potential if it comes
through respect and interchange
considerably over the total we're
required to provide
so i think we should be resisting these
developments
thank you casey would you like to come
back on that yes please chairman um i
just like to speak to the figures so
essentially how we come to the
additional pictures that are required is
that in 2019 a survey was conducted so
that was based on the population of the
existing unauthorized sites an allowance
for children growing up and needing
their own pitch an assumption around the
formation of new pitches so that's how
we came to the to the conclusion that
based on the number of pitches that were
permitted and unauthorized including
those other provisions as well in 2019
there was a need for 18 additional
pitches
so it although perhaps 38 are provided
at present it that doesn't mean that
there isn't an additional need that we
have to accommodate for
so
based on the 2019 application there were
two appeals lost four pictures granted
and then we granted planning permission
for an additional pitch in august so
that is five pictures which have been
granted
um so
that kind of addresses how
we've come to the fact that it's not
that we've provided 38 and there's only
18 needed is because
when that survey was done it takes into
account what is existing what is
potentially going to come forward and
looking at the need for the future
um however based on the stats as well
that
i think been passed around they
they
look at
the unauthorized sites and the
authorized sites so they unauthorized
doesn't count towards our supply they
only count towards our needs
and the list also doesn't actually
define what is a gypsy and traveler it
shows it as a whole of what on our
unauthorized sites in terms of mobile
homes but it doesn't address
what sites of those are gypsy and
traveler and meet that definition
and so it doesn't actually show an
accurate depiction of the supply of
gypsy and traveler sites so
these stats that are included within the
officer report are the updated version
so we
needed to provide 18 we provided five
and there are 13 sites that we still
need to provide to be able to
demonstrate that we meet that supply
thank you chairman thank
you councillor i'm just councillor
stanley oh are you okay with that answer
um yeah i he will hear what you say um
to me i'm not anti gypsy a traveler um
so the distinction you make between
travel sites and other greenfield
incursions
that doesn't
influence me at all uh if we've got 38
we're over a quota
well the officers explained it i can't
explain it any better i'm afraid
thank you for this chairman um just to
i would like to there's some questions
i'd like answered by the officers
first of all
is it
true that a gypsies and travelers site
will be moving their equipment from the
site
sometime during the year to find work
elsewhere
if that is so
who is going to look after the
mentally handicapped person that's on
the site
and where is
they going to go and where have they
been
before they entered the site in the
first place
what is the
special circumstances
appertaining to
a gypsy and traveler's site to be
warranted to go on to green belt
and
another one is we have 17 unauthorized
sites
if we was to make those sites authorized
then we would have our quota
as to the sites that we actually need so
my answer my question is why have we not
authorized those sites that are
and we have one temporary site
which is
to be authorized or not
and where are we with that
in the way of planning
thank you
thank you thank you chairman um so in
terms of the gypsy and traveler
the gypsy travelers moving their
equipment to find work elsewhere
we have not been informed that that is
the work that they participate in that
they would go out to find work elsewhere
and so there isn't a need in our as far
as we are concerned that there needs to
be anybody to look after the daughter
when they move out for work our
understanding is that they have ceased
travel and that's why they're looking
for a permanent basis and that's on the
fact that due to age and the
the need to care for the daughter as
well that's why they've ceased travel so
um the absolutely could you speak up
oh sorry
is that better that's better yeah sorry
did you hear my answer did you want me
to remember i only heard part of it
something about
they're not travelling or whatever
that's okay i'll repeat myself that's
fine i couldn't quite get that that's
okay so
the when a lot of the understanding that
the applicant still travels to work our
understanding is that they've ceased
travel and that's why they're needing
this permanent base and the reason for
ceasing travel is due to age and the
circumstance of the daughter's mental
health
and
so the need to care for her and that's
why they've ceased travelling so
there isn't a need for somebody to come
onto the site to look after the daughter
because the applicant wouldn't be
travelling for work
um
the daughter the advocate did provide
details of where the daughter did
previously he
sent in some comments that were
published following the previous
committee the daughter lived outside of
the home previously
but due to her personal circumstances
which were redacted because of the
nature of them
she
was no longer able to live in that
premises to
for her own safety essentially and so
that is why she is now being cared for
by her father
um can i just interrupt you there please
just for a moment yep she'll be on her
own won't she in this unit
so or is her father moving in with them
no so the the two mobile homes are
obviously near to each other but roman
egyptians traditionally can't share one
mobile home they have to have separate
mobile homes and that's
that that's their culture so it
although
they're not living in the same mobile
home
they are in close enough proximity which
means that she has the assistance of in
through of independent living um in
terms of the special circumstances they
were set out in their report but they
primarily include the fact that we can't
meet our five years supply there's a
lack of alternative accommodation
there's a lack of available work
alternative accommodation and the
personal circumstances which again have
been set out in the report
and so
in terms of the 17 unauthorized sites
and why we haven't authorized these is
simply because they haven't come forward
as planning applications
and then the temporary site and why that
hasn't come forward or where the status
is i don't know what that application is
and it's not a material consideration of
this application so i wouldn't have any
comments to add on that thank you
chairman
um
councillor foster then council sorry
i didn't realize that they had to have
separate accommodation and thank you for
informing me of that
however she obviously was living with
somebody
because they didn't have separate
accommodation
so and
quite honestly i do think that if she
has mental
illness
then living on a on her own is not quite
the right thing for us to decide that
she should do that because i for one do
not want to be
granting this application if she's
living on her own with a mental illness
i don't think that is advisable i think
that should be that we should to a man
say that somebody should look after her
and be in her
contact
rather than away from her contact i
don't think this is advisable situation
thank you
um i'm going to get um
councillor
fd just to speak on that and then i'm
going to get councillor do you want to
speak on it or not
i'm just going to say it's not really
relevant to the planning all this about
the daughter's mental health it's not
really something we should really take
into consideration i don't think what
under special circumstances uh
councillor fd it's a special
circumstance
can you please not argue i'm not having
this people arguing well i've just been
told that it's under special
circumstances so he's actually excuse me
i'm not having anyone arguing this or
i'll stand up and completely close the
meeting
cancer foster
thank you chairman um
this item was discussed at great length
in the last meeting
and i believe that the reason that we
put forward for deferral at that meeting
have been addressed by the officers in
the report
so i'd move a motion for approval
with an amendment of wording in
condition 3 on page 6.2
in the sentence beginning when land
ceases to be occupied by mr barry turner
taylor sorry or his resident dependence
change the word or to end
we discussed that last time
and at the end of the last sentence in
in
that condition i believe we should add
the words at the residence cost
are you happy with that katie
um it would be at the residence cost
anyway it wouldn't be for the council to
carry that cost
um so it wouldn't necessarily
it wouldn't be necessary to add that
sentence however i don't think it would
kind of jeopardize the con the condition
but it probably isn't necessary to add
that part because it would be at the
applicant's cost but i'm happy with the
wording of the and being changed
if i'm a chairman i
do understand that but being somewhat
cynical about certain things i would
recommend that we have that wording to
make sure the onus is on the occupants
to return it to the state it was before
the
occupation of those
caravans are all members happy with that
have you got a second for your motion
counselor will second the motion for
approval
sorry could we at the end of it could we
say instead and the land owners at the
land owners cost
would that be acceptable sorry repeat so
at the end of the
at the end of the condition could we say
at the land owners cost as opposed to
the residence cost yes yeah yep you're
happy with that thank you we have a
second of the motion for approval which
is councillor uh mill
but before that we did have uh
councillor lisa newport and i'd like her
just to
say what you have to please
thank you
i have a couple of questions can you
lift your mic up please i have a couple
of
i have a couple of questions if i'm if i
may i'd like to know what your
definition for a gypsy and traveler is
i'd also like to ask about the
mental health issues and in regards to
the special circumstances that the gypsy
and traveller community are given over
over
um
non-gypsy and traveller community
and also with regards to the sites even
with the um
not including the unauthorized sites
we've still got 23 authorized sites and
the leader of the council has made a
commitment to to investigate a
compulsory purchase order for site gt1
which is the michelin farm site which
would then bring the total number of the
gypsy and traveler sides
including the unauthorized sites to over
53 within within our district
so if that site is then purchased what's
going to happen to all the unauthorized
sites are they then going to be closed
down
or what you know because we're going to
have we're going to have a an awful lot
of individual pitches
and also with regards to your um plan
and the caravan
marked with x not being able to move
around the site who's going to check
that and enforce it when it does when it
is moved
right katie could you answer those
please
then we're going to go ahead and then
we're going to talk to the motion yeah
okay i must admit
i don't have to say katie did actually
go through um
the allocation of science allocation
sites beforehand so i don't think that
needs to be addressed again unless casey
wants to i'm happy to clarify i
appreciate that the stats can be a bit
confusing yeah no problem um in terms of
the definition of the gypsy and traveler
that's um that's discussed in the
planning policy for traveller sites um
so there is a set definition i don't
remember it off the top of my head but
it essentially says that
whether someone's a gypsy and traveler
and whether they have
whether they travel or have cease to
travel yes
no sorry sorry sorry i just clarify the
question no you can't not for a minute
i'd like the officer okay no excuse me
council of newport you've asked a number
of questions we would like those
answered then you could come back yeah
let's do it that way please thank you
thank you chairman um so in terms of the
mental health issues and why this is
considered as a special circumstance for
gypsy and traveller sites essentially
it's because the very special
circumstances that we have to weigh up
on the green belt balance includes
personal circumstances so we have to
understand why somebody has chosen to
cease to travel and why they are
choosing this as a permanent site and in
this instance is partly because of the
mental health issues of the daughter so
with the settled community
we would have to look at very special
circumstances for a greenbelt
application to weigh up that balance and
that would be a material consideration
but it is the personal circumstance of
the applicant in this case that means
that we have to give that further
consideration
um in terms of 23 on authorized sites
this is
i think what council shaw was alluding
to that we were discussing before so
essentially in 2019 when this survey was
conducted we looked at all the sites
that were
in the in the district whether they were
authorized or unauthorized we look at
what the
demand for that would be in the future
in terms of the children and you have to
calculate an expected demand for people
that are going to come into the district
and you work out how many
pitches are going to be needed in the
future and that was calculated as 18
additional pitches so whether they were
when they were authorized or
unauthorized at that time we still
needed 18 additional from that point
we've only seen five be authorized since
that time and so we still need 13. so it
doesn't matter whether there's 23
authorized sites because that was taken
into account when we did that 2019
survey
because we're looking at every every
year there is new there is more demand
and more demand and that survey is
looking at what that demand is at that
point in time so there was a original
survey done in 2016 where we saw that
there was 19 additional pitches that was
then done again in 2019 and there were
18 additional so in that time there had
been the
there had been a reduction of one
basically but yeah it's looking at what
that demand is and we have to be able to
meet the supply of that demand
um and then
the leadership the leaders inquiry about
the compulsory purchase order that isn't
a material consideration of the
application because it hasn't progressed
to a point that is in front of us
and so we can't take that into account
at the moment if it was to progress with
eagle to a point we would be able to
take it into account but it's not for
development management to put forward an
application and so we can't take that
into account as it stands however if
that was to come forward it wouldn't
then mean that all of the other
authorized sites already would have to
be removed it would just mean that we
meet our supply of the moment and so we
wouldn't have to permit these windfall
developments that we see coming forward
it would mean that
in well until we have a new server and
we can see what the demand is presently
but as of the 2019 survey we would meet
that demand if that application were to
come forward now
um and then who's going to enforce the
um
sighting of that caravan would be our
enforcement team if we had reports of
the
mobile home being moved around the site
our enforcement team would be able to go
out to the site and request that it
moved to the position as marked on the
layout plan okay thank you thank you
members sorry can i just come back with
that
one more because i wanted to clarify the
question counseling you let you come in
after we've had a motion on the table
before approval
so for clara what clarification do you
need please
i wanted to say um ask about you say
about um the pitches and
um pictures being classified for gypsy
and traveller community whereas some of
the pictures that have already been now
we've authorized this one now
at newport
i'll get there
whereas you say that some of the pitches
on that are already authorized are not
um considered for gypsy and travellers
that's why i was asking what what your
definition for a gypsy and traveler was
and how you can define between some
pictures that have been authorized that
you're saying are not gypsy and
travellers pitches and some that you're
saying are applications for gypsy and
travelers just to clarify that's not
what i was saying i'm saying that the
excel spreadsheet that states about
unauthorized unauthorized sites doesn't
declare whether or not those sites meet
the gypsy and traveler
definition
so that's not to say that all the on all
the authorized sites they whether they
meet
the gypsy in traveler definition or not
is saying that that list of excel
spreadsheets which states all authorized
and authorized sites they don't
necessarily show what meet the gypsy and
travel the definition or who are just
people living in mobile homes thank you
thank you chairman excuse me i'm gonna
stop the meeting
yeah so right we've got a motion on the
table for approval
we've had a second uh is everyone oh
can i have a vote to say we're going to
go for the emotion except the motion
that's on the table
with the amendment that counsellor
fosters
that's what's going to
be
right i was going to ask
if the members
would vote on the motion with the
amendment
then we're doing then we'll vote on the
motion for approval
yeah
it's all right yeah
okay members right councillor foster
seconded by councillor mill
with the amendment
uh
all members can have a vote to say they
are
are in favor of just
the motion with the amendment
we're not voting for approval we're just
voting for the motion with the amendment
that has been put forward can i have a
show of hands for
that agreement please
any against
any against any of stein extension and
one of the state
councillor mrs newport
right we now have a motion on table for
approval of this application members can
i please have a show of hands for
approval of the application
right thank you
against members
members that is carried seven four five
against no abstentions thank you
your agenda pack it is shown
as
22.00626 stroke full it should be
thank you to councillor foster 2200 229
full
[Music]
pumping station watery lane
how to i believe katie power yes we'll
present the officers report thank you
thank you chairman
sorry um the application spot is located
on the northern side of watery lane some
300 meters west of the junction made
with hull bridge road um
which way should i have addressed it
then
yes i'm asking that's exactly what i'm
asking yes
katie
yeah sorry i think i'm just getting used
to the position yeah yeah okay so we're
all new to this katie and we've got
problems here tonight sorry sorry don't
apologize uh the application site is
located on the northern side of watery
lane some 300 meters west of the
junction made with hull bridge road so
the hubbard road is just off the screen
where the google earth sign is
but waterville lane is here as you can
see and the application site is just
this bit of card standing that you can
see if you go to the next one please
um so you can see
the white
um touring caravan and then the mobile
home here
so the site is located to the west of
the gypsy and traveller site known as
pumping station which is here
and on site there are a number of
structures that have been provided to
you
to serve the use of the site for the
keeping of animals the mobile home was
originally used for a restaurant
associated with the keeping of the
animals but has been used for
residential purposes since around 2008.
plan permission is sought for the
proposed use of land for a gypsy and
traveler pitch comprising the retention
of a mobile home touring caravan
vehicular access and driveway
so on the screen we can see the existing
mobile home is here the touring caravan
here and then this is the access from
watery lane and then the driveway that
extends up here
the mobile home and touring caravan are
positioned centrally along the western
boundary
members may be familiar with the
application site as an application was
refused and dismissed appeal in 2009 and
a subsequent application was recommended
for approval by officers and refused by
the development committee in 2013.
it should be noted that whilst the 2009
application was dismissed at appeal this
was determined prior to the introduction
of the mppf in 2012 which resulted in
material change in policy including the
approach to gypsy and troubler sites
the applicant claims gypsy and traveller
status and this has been supported by
the determination of the previous
applications which asserted the
applicant status as a gypsy and traveler
the principal consideration of the
application is the impact of the
development upon the green belt the
policies relating to this are laid out
within the officers report
the proposal would introduce a permanent
mobile home a touring caravan and
hardstanding on what was essentially an
undeveloped field
the proposal for residential development
would be considered to constitute urban
sport within the green belt equating to
inappropriate development that is
harmful by definition the development
must therefore demonstrate that there
are very special circumstances which
outweigh the harm to the green belt
policy h7 of the core strategy sought to
allocate 15 pitches by 2018 and this was
reflected through the allocation of gt1
at michelin's farm
due to various complications and
difficulties development of this site is
yet to commence and the council have not
exercised its power formally to
compulsively purchase it there are no
other available allocated or public
sites available for occupation within
the district and therefore the council's
requirement to deliver gypsy and travel
pitches must be accommodated elsewhere
further to this the latest formal
assessment of the district's need
identified a need of up to 18 additional
pitches for households meeting the ppets
definition
of a traveler with a further three
pitches for households where it is
unknown whether the definition is met
there has been the recent grant in the
planning permission for five pitches and
therefore there remains a need for at
least 13 pitches dedicated to households
meeting the ppets definition
as such the council are unable to
demonstrate a five-year supply of sites
for gypsy and travelers and this should
be given a significant weight in the
greenbelt balance in addition the lack
of alternative provision should also be
attached to significant weight
whilst a medical letter was submitted
with the application it was not
considered that this equated to a
personal circumstance which restricted
the location of the applicant to the
current site
therefore while substantial weight is
given to the harm to the greenbelt
significant weight is also attached to
the need for gypsum traveller sites the
lack of supply
the lack of supply of sites particularly
the uncertainty in bringing forward the
only allocated site the absence of local
policy and the lack of available
alternative accommodation for the
applicant
in this case there are a number of
matters which are considered to weigh
significantly in favor of the
application and this conclusion would be
consistent with the outcome of recent
appeal decisions
subsequently the cumulative weight of
these very special circumstances would
clearly outweigh the substantial harm
rising from inappropriate development in
the greenbelt despite the applicant's
inability to demonstrate personal
circumstances
in terms of the impact of the
development upon other considerations
there have been no objections from
neighboring properties and as a site has
existed since 2008 it is likely that any
disturbance would have been would have
been raised
the access bin has been constructed in
accordance with the details submitted
with the 2013 application in which the
highway authority raised no objection
the application form states that the
method of how far drainage is displayed
is disposed is unknown as such a
condition has been imposed requesting
details of the foul drainage on-site and
a maintenance plan to ensure its upkeep
the application site is located in an
area identified as at a low to medium
risk of surface water flooding the
application form states that the surface
water would be disposed through a soak
away however no details have been
submitted and so a condition has been
recommended requiring the details of the
surface water drainage proposed the
application is recommended for approval
chairman subject to the conditions set
out in the office of report thank you
very much uh councillor newport mr
newport do you need would you like to
say anything
thank you
uh councillor crips council sustaining
council
please yes please
i won't take you through the same
question and answer the session again so
i'll take that as a read you know be the
same question
okay i'd like to move on to a more
what i think is a crunchier i think to
some extent the i'm sympathy with the
officers i think they are compromised to
some extent all the while we don't have
the allocated local plan allocated
michelin farm site
and as katy has said
several times this evening
there was a estimate of need in 16 there
was an excellent estimate of need in 19
it's now 2022.
we're four years beyond the deadline for
provision the 15-bit site
they're compromised i think they can
only come up with one answer and i think
then that tends to compromise this
committee with whatever we come up with
quite frankly and i think we as a
committee should be pushing upwards
for a solution
uh beat that to planning policy i'm not
sure if that's the right route for it or
it's an executive decision to get this
solved because what we're doing and what
i'm against is this piecemeal
consumption of the greenville
but that's not the only issue
if you look at the definition of the
official traveler's side it's controlled
it's managed it's operated this piece
meal
dicing up of individual sites no control
whatsoever
we've already seen on some sites where
people build things without planning
permission and we find out sometime
later
so
as a committee i think we need to be
pushing upwards to the management if you
like
and say this needs to be a top priority
we've got a new local plan i'm a realist
it's not gonna be done under the night
we've got a new local plan
preferred options
due
not so very far away a few months away
that should be dealing with this in my
opinion
and until that's dealt with i will
continue to oppose keep developing on
the greenville side as an easy way out
of policy policy
thank you thank you
i have noted your comments and i'm sure
the officers have perhaps that can be
addressed outside of this meeting
and
may can i suggest with the officer's
support that if a meeting is
arranged for councillor crips to
actually address uh
well perhaps
pick up separately yeah because you're
right it's a local plan issue
so cats
the crips
will speak to you separately on this
matter outside this meeting okay thank
you thank you
council stanley
have you got anything to say
yes please chairman thank you very much
for this opportunity are you speaking to
mike bring it forward please council
stanley
thank you for this opportunity to speak
to the committee
um first of all
do we know anything of the foul drainage
that's on the site
from the last one that we had it was
noted where the
effluent
pickup was
there doesn't seem to be anything on
this site at the moment
also
as
we know that there is some sort of
problem with the drainage from that site
that goes into the river thank you very
much
also i did notice that we have a
a medical issue with this
application as well
do we know what that medical issue is
we can't do that um
as the the occupant has to will be
living
alone again
and what what the circumstances are to
that as they are special circumstances
and should be dealt with in a medical
condition that whatever it is i assume
um also the
the fact that we're putting another
caravan or whatever you like to call it
i note that the person doesn't want to
travel any longer
and will be residented on that site
without any travelling if that is the
case it can't be considered as a
traveler safe status
i don't see how you can class it as a
traveler status because they're not
traveling again
why are we doing these things
um
there is a basis of
there is a basis for for
the traveling fraternity and yes i do
agree there is one in basildon and
there's one in other
councils
we we don't seem to be understanding how
we are dealing with this situation
except that we are losing our green belt
time and time and time again we will not
have any green belts that's stunning
have you actually a question for our
officers thank you yeah okay um
before katie comes back
uh phil drain wants to answer come in
please
thank you chairman
we need to be clear on
what's in the office's report around
planning policy for travellers site that
defines what a gypsy and traveler is and
it defines a gypsy and traveler
according to non-traveller status so
that's not something that this counselor
is advising on that is defined within
policy i'd advise members to be familiar
with that when making decisions like
this
and and
i i think that's been explained by katie
fowler on both of these applications
katie would you like to come back thank
you thank you
and so in terms of the found drainage
this was addressed within the report so
they in the application form they stated
it was unknown what the foul drainage
was on site considering that they've
been there since 2008 i imagine there is
something in place but we don't know
what that is so there is a condition
attached to
as recommended to request those details
and a maintenance plan to so that
officers can understand what that is
um
in terms of drainage into the river that
wouldn't be permitted by the ea if that
is going on that would be covered by
separate legislation but when we get the
details if the application was approved
then we would be able to understand what
the drainage is on the site
so the medical issue isn't the specific
medical issue isn't a special
circumstance
they did present it as a as a personal
circumstance
um but we can't disclose what the
specific medical issue is so we didn't
consider that in this instance it did
did constitute a personal circumstance
because the medical issue
as provided by a doctor's letter
wasn't something that couldn't be dealt
with by any gp
i think kind of what we're drawing
comparisons to is the previous
application and there was a psychiatric
letter that was provided at that
location which explained why
this
site would benefit that applicant
whereas that hasn't been demonstrated on
this site so officers felt that it
wasn't
a circumstance that couldn't that meant
that he couldn't be
accommodated anywhere basically
and then the purpose of the touring
caravan it's not known however it does
form what we constitute as a pitch so a
pitch normally forms a
mobile home a touring caravan and a day
room and
in this circumstance they haven't
proposed a day room but they have got a
touring caravan and a mobile home and
that's the expected
kind of ancillary uses that come with
the gypsy and travellers site so it's
not uncommon for us to witness such a
thing
although we understand that the
applicant has ceased travelling that
doesn't mean that
they wouldn't go out in the touring
caravan and we it wouldn't really be an
integer material consideration to
question
why that's on the site because it is
included within the definition of what a
pitch is
um so it wouldn't really be reasonable
for us to question that in too much
detail as what they're looking for
meets a gypsy and travellers site
i think that kind of hopefully answers
the questions
thank you okay can i just ask question
please
in the instance of what you say is what
what we
what what is definitely a definite
definition of a traveler's site with a
touring caravan and a mobile home or a
static mobile home and as the person
isn't going to be touring
could we not put condition in there that
the the touring caravan isn't required
because it's i'm just going on the basis
that
it's becoming loaded with
touring caravans and
and caravan site it looks
more like it's going to be occupied by
others rather than those people that are
going to use it and if they're not going
to tour then they won't be using the
touring caravan so could we not put that
in there to remove the touring caravan i
don't think it would be reasonable for
us to do that as it's part and parcel of
the culture what we're permitting is the
use of this site by this type of this
group of people and so it's
it
yeah it wouldn't really be reasonable
for us because it's part and parcel of
the culture
we have put a condition in that says as
condition four so it says save for one
vehicle not exceeding seven and a half
tons in weight no vehicle over three and
a half tons of weight shall be stationed
parked or stored on the land and all
vehicles shall be used chubby for the
use of the occupiers have development
here by permitted only so it does
prohibit they're being overloaded with
kind of numerous vehicles
but i don't think it would be reasonable
for us to prohibit the use of a touring
caravan on the basis that the applicant
has seized travel because they may they
may decide to
go to the shop in the touring cabin it's
it's not really fair for us because it
is part and parcel of their culture and
to have a touring caravan it wouldn't be
fair for us to kind of depict
whether or not they're allowed one on
the site as somebody who lived in the
greenbelt could have a touring campaign
on their driveway for example so i don't
think it would be reasonable for us to
impose that
thank you um i've got councillor fd then
council in newport news councillor
knights
thank you chairman
um it's not really a question you say an
observation
we've got
if this one goes through 11 more sites
that could come forward which basically
with the
with a lack of traveler sites we sort of
got to
agree them otherwise it go to appeal and
we'll probably lose it appeal which i
feel very uncomfortable about
this one is slightly different from the
other one because the personal surface
circumstance the medical left wasn't
taken into account it just seems to be
on that we haven't got enough pitches
so
i'm very uncomfortable with this and
personally i don't think i could
probably support this
so that's just my personal opinion on
this one thank you
please
thank you if i can
we're asked to consider some of these
applications on medical grounds or
personal circumstances special
circumstances but we're not allowed to
know what those special circumstances
are i understand that everyone's
entitled to their privacy but when
you're asking us to consider an
application and that's meant to carry
some sort of weight why are we not given
the full information
simply because it's private and
confidential information the of the
trust really should be with officers
that we're giving you the information
necessary to make that decision and
we have to redact the information that
would
be
kind of a gdpr breach to the applicant
and if i may come back at you on that
discount this council is meant to be
councillor-led not officer-led so you're
asking the members to make
a decision on an application but you're
not giving the members the full
information
it's not really
thank you chairman i think it's
it's what's in the public domain um it
may well be possible for members to have
conversations with officers to find out
that information knowing that that's
private information i think the key
issue here is that we're making a
decision based on information that would
then be in the public domain
i appreciate
the
issue
because we are sorry to interrupt people
but we are given
finish but then you can come back later
please
we are given information that is private
and confidential on other matters it
just seems really not
we're not given the full picture it may
sway and a a vote
if we're given the full picture that's
all i'm saying that's all i wanted to
ask
i appreciate what you're saying but
obviously in this circumstance we're not
actually attributing any weight to the
medical condition so i don't think it
would apply to this planning application
will be a material consideration
personally i would as one personally i
would find it very uncomfortable if any
medical uh information on this as you
say it's for a personal domain and if i
was having an application for myself and
it was medical i would not want that to
go out but that's only my personal
opinion counselor knight
thank you chairman um
correct me if i'm wrong what you said
they live alone on this site
um i think you they said they live a
lion loan um i understand that they've
purchased this land so do they pay
council tax
and who enforces that
um and you said that no vehicles over a
certain
weight is allowed to be stored on the
site what about the horse boxes
that are on there
please um so whether or not they pay
council taxes and a material
consideration of the planning
application they would have to pay
council tax as far as i understand but
it's not a material consideration the
horse boxes aren't subject to the
application so whether or not there's
any stored as the officer i'm not
familiar
and this relates solely to the gypsum
traveler use
thank you thank you councillor williams
get you wrong
thank you chairman um i can see little
difference between this application and
the last one and it would be
improper i think to refuse this
application at the moment
as a council we have let our residents
down we have not provided sufficient
a gypsy and traveller sites
therefore at this point i would like to
propose that we go to a vote for
recommendation have you a second
please
[Music]
i have a question actually um
um two questions i will be really quick
the
no we need you to have a microphone
sorry i apologize um
three point
lost it now that's good
3.8 3.9 talks about the land being
previously agricultural land can i just
ask um are really animals actually kept
on that land
because my understanding is that's what
its prime use is for and i understand
that that's green belt lamb but to me
that's important and my second question
is are there any other special or
mitigating circumstances in this
application
thank you
thank you chairman um so
at present there are only animals or
officers understand to be kept on the
site are geese and dogs so it was put
forward as a
consideration that the land was
agriculture and use officers didn't
consider it to be a formal agricultural
use
and so we didn't give that any policy
weight so although there are animals
kept on the scientists wouldn't
constitute in offices view a formal
agricultural provision
um and so the special circumstances
of the case would be the lack of
five-year supply lack of alternative
sites lack of local policy lack of
available alternative sites and although
the personal circumstance isn't
given
significa isn't given a significant way
it's considered that the fact that there
are four other
very special circumstances
which need to be attributed to
significant weight that still tilts the
green belt balance in favor of the
application
thank you
dr mitchell
yeah because we are supposed to be
talking to the motion
so go on please quickly is there any
agricultural tie on that greenbelt land
at all
not as far as officers are aware okay
thank you thank you
right members we have a motion on the
table for approval seconded by
councillor butcher
um
council williams put the motion forward
members can i have a vote for approval
of this application please the show of
hands
against please
yes
but there's five four five against
two of suspensions i have the casting
vote i'm voting for thank you
right members
item eight
22 strokes zero zero four four one full
land of
12 to 26 eastwood road raley
i believe it's kt
rogers will be thank you thank you
welcome
just if just give us a moment
okay thank you chad
right
just turn that on sorry phil you might
need to
thanks
so members this site is located between
eastwood road which is um here
and castle road car park and castle road
in this position here
on the edge of rayleigh town centre
the site has won vehicular access at
this point here off eastwood road
which also serves the car parked to the
rear of the commercial
premises here and the car park
the site directly
is bordered also sorry the site's also
bordered by castle road car park and
some residential properties so we have
residential properties in britain court
which is a purpose-built flooded block
we also have a residential property 14
finch field
and some more premises on eastwood road
here
you can take me to the approved yeah
thank you
so planning permission um for 41 flats
was approved at this site in january
2020
and the plan on the screen shows the
approved site
site layout and you can see that there
were two blocks
um one
sorry
block a here
and block a sort of followed the
northern boundary of the site
and block b here
the application before members this
evening seeks to make changes to this
previously approved consent
so now if i can show you
a comparison site
layout right so we might we'll maybe
need to zoom into this a little bit if
you can
yeah thanks claire but show both of them
that's okay
so on screen what we have is both the
approved site layout which is um on the
right hand side here oh gosh sorry
um here
and the proposed site layout on the left
hand side
so the amended proposal still seeks the
development of the site for 41 flats
split between two separate flatted
blocks so you can see still we've got
block a following the northern boundary
and block b here which is
you know the same essentially as the
approved scheme
no change is proposed to block b which
is is the smaller block here
um there are some changes to the
approved um block a which i'll go on to
shortly but first first once we've got
these two site layout plans i'll just
take you through some of the changes
that they proposed to the site layout
so a shared surface street
so in this position i'm showing with the
light here is still proposed so this is
the approved scheme
and this is the proposed scheme
but in this position approximately here
it just um skews slightly later within
the site it's a bit difficult to see
because of the coloration on the
approved scheme
but this
tilt here is just slightly deeper into
the site and the position of the turning
head changes slightly so previously the
turning head was in this position here
quite close to the front elevation of
flatted block a
and now the turning head is in this area
here there's a slight change to the
layout there
the parking layout is also proposed to
be slightly different
so the proposal includes one additional
space in this area here
so if you counted the number and i
appreciate that's difficult to do
whilst looking at the scale of this plan
but in this location here versus
this location here there's one
additional space proposed
more parking would also be proposed here
so just um in front of this elevation of
block a here versus what was previously
proposed in this area here so more car
parking there
um
one less space is proposed um to the
southern side of the um here so in this
in this area here there's less parking
spaces proposed than was previously
agreed in this location here
overall um the site as proposed now has
two additional car parking spaces so
you've got 43 car parking spaces that
will be provided in total now and and
two of the spaces now proposed are
proposed to be electric vehicle charging
point spaces and that wasn't the case on
the previous consent
as a result of the proposed changes to
the parking layout
where the soft landscaping would be
provided between and around parking
spaces also inevitably changes slightly
but what there would still be is space
to accommodate some soft landscaping so
to this part here
um
and then
in this part here and between some of
the the spaces as well and around them
the sighting of refuse stores um is also
proposed to change
now
if you could claire zoom into the
approved
site layout please
just move across thank you
okay
so what was approved was a refuse store
in this location here
sorry
um one here
and one in this location here okay so we
had three locations on the site as
approved where um residents were going
to be able to you know store or the bins
were going to be stored for waste and
recycling to serve all the 41 flats and
this one here was the larger of the two
so there was a sort of walkway between
um two stores either side
and then if we can go over
to the now proposed plan in terms of
refuse stores
now we have four locations so we have
one here
one here
one here
and then one here this is sort of an
elongated sort of thin but longer area
where refuse bins would be stored here
so if you can now zoom sorry back so we
can see both of
them thank you
so concerns have been
raised um from residents in britain
court in relation to the sighting of
refuse stores as proposed and the
concerns relate to
issues of smells and flies
what you have is the shed a communal
amenity space that serves britain court
right up against the boundary of the
southern boundary of this site
and so these refuse stores are going to
be in close proximity to that boundary
so what officers have given
consideration to
is
what
the developer has consent for
and what we see here is we already have
a refuse store in this on this corner
here and it's not vastly dissimilar to
where this one is proposed here now so
it it is a different um angle so now the
the bins are sort of alongside rather
than at 90 degrees two but it's in the
essentially the same position
um this one here though
wasn't there previously it was
previously parking
this one here
if you can
sort of compare it to this one here so
what we have
is
one here now now previously we had a
much larger store
closer to the boundary albeit shifted
now it's shifted slightly south
and as proposed now there is some
potential for some soft landscaping in
between that refuse store and the
boundary whereas there wasn't potential
for that um or space to accommodate that
in the approved layout
and this this bit refuse store is new
okay so that that wasn't proposed as
part of that um
approved layout
so officers have given consideration to
these matters and
we don't officers view is that the
proposed locations of the refuse stores
um are in light of what was approved are
acceptable
um but what officers are not satisfied
with is the design of these bin stores
so claire i know it might not be in the
right order but there is um an elevation
to show yes thank you
so this is the elevation of the proposed
refuse stores that the developer seeks
to provide so and what they are is
essentially
open
on top so there's no roof to the
structure it's essentially sort of
timber fencing type with doors that open
to the front
and officers consider that if you can go
back to the layout clear
in such close proximity to the boundary
and given the
residential
or sort of the communal amenity space
adjacent that that's that's not um
adequate so what we have recommended is
a condition that requires these to be
roofed structures and it's still if you
look at the condition i haven't got the
number to hand to tell you what number
it is but it's in the report
it does seek to ensure that they are
ventilated so what we don't want is
entirely enclosed refuse store buildings
because you need some air circulation
but what we say is that the vent the
gaps if you like could be to the front
elevation facing the development rather
than
you know any gaps facing onto the
boundary treatment
with britain court's boundary
so there will be required to be roofed
structures
um and
sorry
it's condition 15 if you wanted to have
a look at the wording of it thank you
claire
so given that condition um and given the
approval officers are content that there
would be
um that the the proposed arrangement
would be acceptable if i can just take
you please just some photos what what i
have got is a few photos of the site
that i took on a fairly recent site
visit
um the site may have progressed
from this um
yep that's fine so that that that's the
first one which is fine thank you claire
so i know you might not record back to
the layout plan but if you can imagine
one of the refuse stores is proposed
just the other side of this this fence
panel that looks like it might be in
need of a bit of repair on the other
side of that and that location is the
location that was already approved for a
refuse store on the approved site layout
and this is a closed-boarded fence to
the boundary but what the applicant does
seek to do is provide a new closed
boarded fence along all of this boundary
with britain court's amenity space so
where you see this metal rail fence here
that obviously is quite open you can see
through and
on the other side of that within the
application site will be a
closed-boarded boundary fence
um so there'll be one refuse store
behind this fence panel there'll be
another one
um about in this location here just the
other side of that fence and claire if
you could take you to the next photo
please
sorry
okay so this is castle road car park and
if you remember from the site layout
there was one elongated so one narrow
but sort of longer refuse store this
would be the other side of this hoarding
essentially along this boundary here
um
claire if you want to go to the next one
so uh yeah okay so this is um
in the approximate position and so just
um beyond where my light is showing
is the other refuse store and there was
a larger refuse store proposed to be
cited essentially maybe just beyond my
light here so just further up so instead
of the largest store you've got that you
would have had
beyond here and it close right up
against the boundary what you're going
to have is a bin store off the boundary
so some soft landscaping in between and
again all of this all of this boundary
will be provided with a closed-boarded
boundary fence
thank you claire
no i think uh i don't need that one
sorry i think i've looked at the other
one
okay so if we can go back to the
comparison of the site layouts please
i'll just point out the other sort of
another change so we the applicant also
proposes to change the location of the
cycle stores so now instead of there
being a cycle store that was being
provided in this corner here so close to
the boundary again with britain court
that's not no longer going to be
provided and it's going to be in this
location here so within the amenity
space here and there's also the
retention of a cycle store in this
location here which was already on the
approved layout and there's also a
smaller one in this location just north
of the refuse store here
which
was always going to be provided but
slightly repositioned because it was
going to be further south on the
boundary in this location and claire i
do i do have a cycle store
so just for members benefit this is the
design of the cycle store that's being
provided so
it won't be a fully enclosed structure
but it will give some protection to
cycles from from the elements
if i can take you now please to the
comparison elevation plans and i don't
propose to take members through every
small change that's proposed to the
elevations of block a because there are
a number of changes but what i will give
you is just a flavor of it so this is um
can you take you to elevation one if
possible
yep thank you
so on the right hand side then you have
the approved elevation one and on the
left hand side the proposed elevation
one
and this is um as you enter the site of
the vehicle access from eastwood road
this would be immediately on your right
hand side
if any member wants me to point out
where this is on the site layout i can
and generally the appearance is very
similar
but what there is is a change if you can
look at this part of the building here
versus this part of the building here
you'll see that there's a change to the
windows there's a change to the roof
form here so this is now a
sloping roof all the way down whereas
there was this
kind of articulation this projection to
the building that was provided here and
actually although i don't have it to
show you this is now provided on the
other side of this elevation that faces
the car park
claire if i can take you to elevation
eight please
thank you right so this is elevation
eight and um again if any member wants
me to point out exactly where this is on
the layout i can
this faces
some of the properties on britain court
so this elevation faces
part of the shared surface that goes be
within the site
and and you can see some of the key
changes here are if you look at the roof
form proposed here
versus this area there is a slight
change here
there is also now proposed a new
um amenity terrace at the third floor
level here so that wasn't proposed on
this elevation here essentially that
that was to be provided but that was on
the other side of the building and they
flipped it to this elevation here
um and then there are some small changes
to the the window positions as well
thank you claire
can i take you to the floor plan please
so there are some changes also
internally within the flatted block a um
and the plan on screen is an extract of
the first floor plan in block a
so again the approved
floor plan is to the right hand side of
the screen and the proposed floor plan
is to the left-hand side it's it's very
difficult i appreciate it's very
difficult to see this so you just have
to
trust me but in this flat here
okay which is the same as this flat here
there are changes to the layout which
mean
essentially a living room kitchen and a
bedroom that had been approved have
flipped positions okay
and throughout there are minor changes
like that so some of the
windows that would be now provided on
this elevation
will instead of serving a
kitchen lounge now survey bedroom
essentially
but the arrangement of windows is very
much the same
as was approved with those slight
changes some of which i've gone through
on the elevation plan
um
can i take you to the comparison third
floor plan of block a as well please so
this is just one other extract i don't
propose to take members through
everything
and
it's it's a bit difficult to see i'm
afraid but the
um
this elevation here there is a balcony
now proposed in this position here
whereas previously it was on the other
side and i think i just mentioned that
on the elevation plan as well
there was also this terrace to be
provided at third floor level on this
corner that's that was already on the
approved scheme but instead of that
being a communal terrorist that is now
proposed to serve a one particular flat
i'll just draw your attention to a
correction so paragraph 3.21 of the
committee report
it should be noted that flat 12
would in fact be provided with a balcony
that wouldn't quite meet the five square
meters but this was previously the case
on the approved scheme in any case all
the other flats at first and second
floor level will be provided with
balconies that would at least meet the
five square meters more in most cases
an amenity space would continue to be
provided to each flat
at ground floor level and taking into
account as we did in the original
members decision to approve the original
scheme
um
king george's playing field is is in
quite close proximity and provides
another
area of communal amenity space that
would be available to people
there is a section 106 agreement
relating to the original consent
which is dated the 17th of january 2020
and this required
affordable housing provision in relation
to the scheme
and the requirements relating to the
delivery of affordable housing would
continue to apply and it's therefore
recommended that in addition to the
planning conditions are set out in the
committee report
that
that any newly granted permission would
also continue to be subject to the
requirements of the 106 legal agreement
and although not noted in the committee
report it's noted verbally now there
would need to be a deed of variation to
secure this as necessary so any
resolution would just need to
reference that need for a deed of
variation to make sure that the
requirements of that 106
still apply
so the recommendation and chairman is
that the amended scheme is acceptable um
subject to the amended to subject to the
conditions are stated in the report and
then on the deed of variation to secure
the
thank 106. so good thank you guys uh
katie
uh
mr
gosnell would you like to come and speak
please you have five
minutes
and i will give you um
the nod when it's one minute
good evening everyone
um chairman
um my name is john gosnell and i
represent britain court i also live at
britain court and part of the committee
for britain court
following a meeting that we held at
britain court on the 14th of july
which included rochas district cannon
planning
councillor mr cross
also the chignol builders
um residents raised concerns raised on
several concerns
one was the overlooking of by the
windows of the new build
and the refuge bin stores and parking
bays
we know that
at this late stage
the windows will not be changed
and i think
most of the residents have come to
accept that
however with regards to the refuge bin
stores
that were proposed along our boundary
fence line
some of these are very close to doors
and windows
for example i live at flat 44
and one of the bin stores
or five meters away from my bedroom
window
this is
a new location from the previous plans
i
as you can see from my photos that the
pre the existing
bins uh the the stores that are there
now
the new one
are all overflowing
food waste
all over the floor
they're not adequate enough i've been in
touch with environmental health which is
um
andrew um
and he's put some recommendations in as
well
he thinks that the bins are not adequate
enough
my concerns are obviously
the one closest to my window
i did make some suggestions to the
council about
or you know switching around with the
bicycle rack to make it a little bit
further away
um so please could you take that in
consideration
but there's also some other residents as
you can see from that picture that we
showed earlier with the gazebo and the
table that's right where the resident
sits and enjoys the garden and you're
going to have a refuge store right
behind it
you know i'm concerned about rodents
smells
we've got bins ourselves and they are
fully enclosed and
and they're away from residence doors
and windows
[Music]
the other the other thing that was
mentioned was about parking
we've also had and we've experienced
quite a few residents being woken up in
the early hours of the morning
with
car revving and
parking
and it's quite a loud vehicle exhaust
noise um so it was suggested at the
meeting or i put forward
some planning for
some soft landscaping
maybe some trees to help with that
um
but all the other amendments to the
actual building uh the residents have
got no comments um quite happy and quite
happy with that
that's me done thank you very much
can you just pass those over
back to them please thank you
we have one more member here councillor
cross
are you is he there
i'm sorry you'll feel hidden sorry
you're right because i had to ask you
because you're all the more member
uh councillor newport
thank you chairman
um members i'll just be very brief um
as you've already heard from the
resident here they've got grave concerns
over the refuse and the location
the glaring omission from this
from this report is that of a
representation from environmental health
so my question to officers would be
did they ask for a representation or did
they consult with environmental health
and why
hasn't environmental health
taken the issues that the residents have
already raised with them prior to this
coming to the committee
into account
now if you pass this
application tonight you are letting
those residents down very badly by not
deferring this application and insisting
that environmental health make a
recommendation
as members are well aware
there is a big problem with rats within
and rodents within the town already
and
i would
recommend
that red that
the committee defers this application
and insists on a report from
environmental health on the bin store
location
thank you members thank you
councillor foster
thank you chairman um i'd made two
points one was about um i was going to
ask about the uh the bins and
the evidence we saw there suggests that
they're in a bad place from a resident
perspective
um but i have a question also on the if
you look at the pictures up there there
appears on the proposed site to be
less
uh
soft landscaping trees and so on is that
the case
yes please casey hello thank you um
let me just point the pointer
so
what
what's potentially um
a bit difficult to to look at these two
plant and judge is that one shows trees
and one doesn't so i suppose what you've
got to do is imagine where trees could
be located within the soft the green
areas
that are shown on this now because there
is this longer strip of car parking
proposed here than was in front of the
building here
this layout won't facilitate trees in
the same position
but officers are satisfied that there is
enough
areas
so there's an area here there's a corner
area here which extends down and this
area is actually
bigger um this area here that than was
on the would allow for soft landscaping
on the approved layout so it's different
um
what i haven't got is an exact
measurement for you you know in square
meters how much you know green sort of
soft landscaping was in front of and
around the buildings
as approved versus what's proposed
but officers are content that there's
sufficient space to allow for tree
planting
what we have is a condition that
recommends the requirement of a soft
landscaping scheme
to be submitted to the council so i
all we have at the moment in terms of a
layout is the one that's on the screen
proposed i don't have a soft landscaping
scheme
to show you to put on the screen that
shows where the applicant intends to
place all the trees but they can be
provided where these green areas
are shown
okay thank you chairman can i come back
yes you can can i um move for deferral
to address the issues with um the bin
storage areas and the resident concerns
i will second that because that's
exactly what i was going to say because
i have got i know this site and i'm very
very concerned about the bin stores i
did take advice from phil to see if we
could actually
uh vote on
each condition separately and otherwise
not so we could have done the three
conditions and then left perhaps
deferred
gone back for more information regarding
um the environmental health advocate and
what he has said
so
cancer stanley i know you've got your
hand up i had not acknowledged you so
you you'd have an eye make otherwise
what would you like to say
thank you thank you chairman um
my first thoughts are to alleviate the
problems with britain court and where
where they are situated in that corner
where we see parking bays
was to put the parking base to the other
side and make the road this side where
the parking bays are so that would
alleviate the problem of
the bin store and the parking bays
because uh obviously that that needs to
be eradicated
on the
i do realize i do realize that at this
late stage perhaps that wasn't picked up
when the plan was put together the
parking of the bin stores and i'm
pleased you picked that up for me as as
well as councillor foster um that the
bin stores
how often are they emptied or are we
going to make a condition on that well
councillor
can i just stop you there yes sir we've
done it
oh we've put up but we'd like it
deferred for the reason of the bean
stores then we once we've put up and if
it's voted on for deferral we can then
ask the officers tell them what advise
the officers
what we need why it's being deferred is
that okay it's all right and then you
can actually put it i didn't know well
what you're saying
yep thank you thank you
so can i just
can i just say okay
of course
sorry so just um we we haven't got a
formal consultation response from
environmental health in the committee
report but we did have some informal
discussions with environmental health
and building control around the issue of
refuse stores
so
there's no objection from environmental
health in principle to where these
stores would be located that is really a
a planning
judgment as to whether they are in
appropriate locations
what we have to give consideration to in
this application
somewhat unusually because it's a
section 73 application which seeks to
vary a condition on an approved scheme
we have to take into account the
approved scheme so we have to take into
account the essentially the fallback as
it were so what the developer has
consent for
as as it stands and they have consent
put the refuse stores oh sorry in the
three positions
shown i appreciate that's different to
the four locations that are now
so the discussions with building control
were around
any building regulations to do with
enclosure of refuse stores and building
control's advice
is that they would support um full
enclosure of those
with the roofs um to limit the the
transfer of smells and potentially flies
and to protect the
bins should they um
be
filled to capacity and the roofs not be
able to close quite properly from the
elements okay so either when it's very
hot or raining etc what you don't want
is um
kind of
rain able to get into those bags and
things
the other issue is um capacity of refuse
stores so i know the resident has
provided some pictures which show bins
overflowing i'm not i don't know how
many flats are occupied on the site or
at present or how many of the refuse
stores they're proposing to provide are
provided
but the number
of refuse stores or the area that's
proposed would meet the guidance that's
set out in appendix one of the
development management plan so that
looks to
calculate how
how big the bin stores need to be based
on the number of flats and the size of
flats proposed and this number of refuse
stores would meet that
requirement i think
also i might add that in the course of
the application
given the concerns i did raise the issue
of the bin store locations um
notwithstanding sort of my own
professional view that the locations are
acceptable
with so i raised the residents concerned
with the applicant's agent
and left them with that to take away and
they came back and
told me that this was the scheme um and
that
there was no change going to be made to
those stores having said that more
recently and very recently they did
suggest that one of them although i'd
didn't see a plan could potentially be
split in split and moved slightly but i
never saw a plan
and in
that was i think in response to my
saying that they would all be required
to be enclosed with roofs so i think if
if an application is deferred i think we
just need to understand what the what
what members
want officers to go back again to the
developer to to seek to
address right what i was going to say
katie that we've had got a deferment on
i've seconded it
we're all very very concerned
i'm talking with emotion now uh about
the location of the bing stores yes
they've loca we've agreed on the
original um
application to have three
there's no reason why we need four
and the and
there's um
we need so we need to them uh
environmental health not to have a
verbal meeting with yourselves
to bring it back to this development
committee to
say that they have not got any concerns
at all because
yes we've seen some photographs
um
and if they're not fully occupied those
it's going to get worse
so if they're going to put bin stores in
they've got to be adequate but they've
got to be covered and they can't be
outside someone's bedroom window so we
need and it's all very well the
developers saying we're not going to
amend this but they they want it amended
because they have they want to put an
extra bin store in when there wasn't one
in the first place
so um i'm going to say can we have a
vote on this councillor stanley
um at the same time madam chairman um
the windows on the second and third
floors
would they be facing
the occupants in their gardens and if
they are would they be a
produce this has been already discussed
on the original plan
you were a part of the development
committee as i was but i don't remember
it
i don't remember it no
but i'm sure our officers will do it so
we're gonna go vote
of course you can
can we have a detailed plan of
the enclosed
rubbish bins are they going to be
out of concrete blocks and ventilated
within
uh
the development rather than ventilated
outside if it's all going to be wood and
someone was to put something in the bin
they shouldn't have done and it burns
down the whole lot goes
so can we have within the amended bit a
detailed
thing of the con
enclosures please
yeah yeah i mean
just on that point i think it's my view
that um the elevation that you saw on
screen which was the developer's
proposal for the refuse stores and which
has been provided at least in part on
site already um with this timber
essentially timber fencing around isn't
insufficient for a site with 41 flats
where they're communal stores and people
i suppose maybe
may not take as good care of that as if
it were just a single house you know
with their own personal refuse store
it's going to have a lot of traffic in
and out of people closing the doors that
they need to be really robust structures
and the policy and the appendix one of
the development management plan backs
that up in terms of um requiring
structures that will withstand
a degree of um you know being bashed
into and things like that so in my view
the deferral list yeah so in my view i
think what you're expecting from the
deferral hopefully is at least officers
attempting to go to the developers
and the developers agent and say we want
an alternative elevation which would
have been required by that condition
anyway and i'm thinking that it should
be formed in brick or something
of that nature
the appendix one to the development
management plan seeks to have refuse
stores in keeping with the actual build
form that's been provided on the site
and there's no timber cladding to any of
the buildings that are you know either
block a or block b so what you might
look for is something rendered or
something like that but i think we
expect something better than that and
we're expecting a roof structure and
like i said before we're expecting it to
be ventilated so we get air circulation
but for that to be really on the on the
front elevation so facing the car park
so we hoped then if deferment is is the
way this goes to come back to you with
another
alternative detail to that
number 15
which is where you basically ask them to
come forward with the design with closed
top um ventilated stock person
my point is that
it starts by saying within three months
of the date of this consent and then it
goes very soft by saying unless an
alternative time frame has been agreed
in writing with the local planning
authority i think that's far too soft to
condition it's an open check to take far
too long to solve this problem
um because it's already a problem it's
featured on um
social media several times been over
flying and so on and i'm a realist the
three months is tight because they've
got a they've got to draw it they've got
to submit it to you get your approval
they've got to procure materials they've
got to build it it is a stiff ass but
given the people's discomfort at the
moment um then i think it needs to be
harsh on the developer not giving him an
open check to take six months
quickly just quickly
i appreciate it can i stop sorry i can't
have two conversations sorry can i just
let have one and then come back thank
you thank you i i see your point and
it's quite difficult to word conditions
like this when the development has
commenced because ordinarily most of
these conditions will be worded prior to
commencement of you know or or prior to
occupation of the difficulty here sorry
would be prior to occupation of we have
occupations at the site so if we worded
it prior to occupation of they had been
breached immediately and it just
wouldn't be very it'd be a bit
nonsensical to word a condition like
that but i did
sort of take time over this and consider
whether this was
reasonable not i appreciate your point
and maybe if if we were
members reminded to go with the
recommendation it could be that you
would suggest a formal amendment to this
um so that you would remove that
leniency of
unless alternative time frame is
submitted and agreed obviously
officers wouldn't agree to a time frame
that's you know taking that to the
extreme we appreciate this is a problem
for the residents that needs to be
solved soon but i think at the moment
what's on the table is potentially not
approval subject to an amended condition
right thank you katie just one and then
i'm going to close it because we've got
emotion on the table we've had it
seconded for deferral and i'd like to
have a vote on that council foster
you can't i can't hear you
you've drooped
can you hear me now right
um i would just add my motion to defer
wasn't just about the structure
it's about the location as well they're
very close to neighbours but within that
development there are spaces that could
be closer to the people who are in the
development
and so i think that needs to be looked
at as well right okay right members
we've got a motion on the table for
deferment with the points that have been
um
discussed and hopefully all noted by our
officers
can i have a vote for approval for
deferment please
that is unanimous
one oh sorry can i do it again sorry
counselor williams
you haven't voted sorry any objections i
know
you're doing it right so
that is 11-1
so it's level four deferment one against
thank you
right it's 9 15 members what a vote to
extend this if it goes on past 10
o'clock
and we have to vote on this at this time
we've got one more can i just ask that
we take a vote that you're happy to
see this uh item nine to the end please
can i have
it
of course you can we're right from now
because we're on the next one it's 9 15
9 20 we will now have a five minute
comfort break
i believe they're outside the doors
vote for the extension
sorry members can either vote for the
extension
we all want the vote for the extension
right yeah thank you
agree thank you very much
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
yes
safety
well done for remembering about the
extension
do you always do a quarter past night
well around right yes so you meant to do
it shortly before half past so yeah it
seemed
the right place hopefully it won't be 45
minutes long
it's probably the easiest one now isn't
it
yeah because it's only here because of
being known
family member yeah
okay
my little setup
[Music]
sorry i'm just going to change the
batteries in your microphones
before we realized
members can we start the meet again
please
[Music]
oh is it not many
is there not many
oh
biscuit wars now
ian is
counselor standing in there
good place
right members we'll start the meeting
again for item nine
it's the land uh 22 stroke zero zero six
two six full land adjacent to
17 bracknell del rayley
and i believe it is claire that
buckley that's going to do the report
thank you claire
chairman this application is for the
erection of a detached three-bed
bungalow with associated parking and
amenity space access would be from the
road brackendell which is located just
here
this application is reported to the
committee because the applicants are
related to a member of staff
as you can see from the location plan
the site is located to the rear of
dwellings along ball lane and to the end
of brackendell
oh sorry
apologies
as you can see from the location plan
the site is located to the rear of
dwellings along ball lane and to the end
of brackendell and is currently the
residential garden to number 125 ball
lane so just located here so this is the
site as you can see this is ball lane
coming along here louise road here
and you can see the properties here at
ball lane so this is actually the garden
area to this property here and we've got
some dwellings located in brackendale
here which is a cul-de-sac
the existing site so i'll show you the
existing site
i appreciate it's a bit faint but this
is the existing site area it's a
residential garden with summer house
workshop greenhouse and shed it has an
existing pedestrian entrance onto
brackendell which is located around
about here so there's no vehicular
access at the moment just pedestrian
access at the end of that road
and this is the proposed plan so the
proposal would demolish the buildings
originally within the rear garden area
and it would replace it with a bungalow
in a central area of the site there
would be a new vehicular crossover onto
brackendell and driveway into the site
with parking area here and then garden
areas all wrapped around in this kind of
position here
and this plant shows the design of the
bungalow proposed so be a simple design
with a pitch driven gable lens material
supposedly include red and buff brick
off-white render and red brown
interlocking roof tiles
so the key material planning
considerations are principle of
development design and impact on the
character of the area impact on
residential amenity garden sizes
sustainability highways flooding and
drainage refuse and waste storage impact
on trees and ecology
so with regards to the principle of
development it should be noted that
outline planning permission for a
bungalow at this site was granted
permission in 2021
therefore the principle of a bungalow at
this site has previously been accepted
the site is considered to be located
within a sustainable location and would
represent the effective use of land
supported by local and national policy
with regards to design and impact on the
character of the area
it is considered that the design of the
proposed dwelling is acceptable i would
not appear cramped within the plot or
detrimental to the character of the area
it would be 4.9 meters high to the ridge
which is considered to be of an
acceptable scale
looking at impact on residential amenity
number 17 brackendell is the closest
dwelling to the application site so
that's the one located
just here
the property is an angle to the proposed
dwelling with no windows to the side
elevation it is not considered to have a
detrimental impact upon this property
the next nearest number one two five and
one two five a ball lane but there is a
distance in excess of 17 meters
separating numbers one two five and one
two five a from the proposed dwelling so
they're the properties at the bottom
here one of which um is obviously the
garden area the actual application site
that we've got here before us
the proposed bungalow would not be
considered to give rise to material
overlooking overshadowing
of neighbouring properties
looking at garden sizes the proposed
dwelling and the resultant dwelling at
number 125 would retain garden areas in
excess of 100 meters squared in
accordance with spd2
looking at sustainability the proposal
would comply with the gross internal
floor space and storage required for
this size of dwelling
water efficiency standards would need to
be met as required by the condition
referred to on the addendum
highways the proposal includes two
driveway spaces in accordance with the
parking standards preferred base sizing
county highways do not object to the
proposal including the new access
subject to conditions so as we've seen
before that's where the actual parking
spaces are and
sorry
thank you so that's where the new
parking spaces would be and obviously
the driver access here and you can see
here there is also space visitor parking
as well located in this area here
flooding and drainage the application
site is located entirely in flood zone
one where there is a low probability of
flooding from rivers and the sea advice
advocated within the mppf states in
order to satisfactorily manage flood
risk in new development appropriate
surface water drainage arrangements are
required a condition to control this has
been attached to the recommendation
looking at refuse and waste storage the
proposed front and rear garden area
would provide sufficient storage space
for the three bins at the site
impact on trees the existing trees and
shrubs are not of high immunity value
and subsequently their removal would not
be of concern a condition relating to
soft landscaping has been included
within the officer's recommendation
which would seek to achieve new tree
planting at the site
and finally ecology the society's
maintained domestic garden and is
therefore unlikely to support protected
species the proposal is within the scope
of the essex coast rams as it falls
within the zone of influence for likely
impacts and is a relevant residential
development type the mitigation in the
form of financial payment has been made
by the applicant
a chairman this application is
recommended for approval subject to the
conditions outlined in the report and
addendum
thank you very much
maybe you've read the addendum already
addendum yes uh
yeah council lacrosse uh
i believe you want to speak on this item
uh you have like others you have five
minutes and we'll give you the nod for
when you've got one minute to go thank
you
[Music]
thank you chairman and uh thank you
members
and officers
um
thank you to the committee for giving me
the opportunity to speak
as i mentioned um
earlier i have a non-pecuniary interest
because i live on the corner of
brackendell actually in louise road
but
i'm basically not affected by this
development apart from
maybe building a
transitory building disruption but
that's not not really a problem
my issue is that from the beginning this
has been a
proposed development of a two-bedroom
bungalow
the report itself is is titled in uh
big letters and bold a two-bedroom
bungalow
and i believe the residents locally have
believed it to be a two-bedroom bungalow
from day one
the addendum came out a week or so ago
saying it's a three-bedroom bungalow
now there are still notices on lamp
posts
in the area in louise road
which states that it's a two-bedroom
bungalow
so
i would like to suggest that um the
consultation that may have taken place
with local residents they would have
believed it to have been a two-bedroom
bungalow
and
more importantly essex county council
and highways department
my question is
have they been working on the basis of
it being a two-bedroom bungalow
because the implications for a 50 larger
bungalow are in terms of number of
residents potentially and their vehicles
and i appreciate there is off-road
parking for two vehicles but um
with potentially uh
a couple living there with perhaps two
children uh grown-up children there may
possibly be three vehicles um on on site
the
[Music]
report states that um
the description will be amended to refer
to the proposal as a three-bedroom
bungalow is not considered necessary to
reconsult and i disagree with that i
believe it is essential to reconsult as
the local residents have had believed it
to be a two-bedroomed
bungalow
there's also later in the reports report
statement to say that
it is
right it is considered item 3.18 it is
considered that the design of the
proposed dwelling house is in keep in
keeping with the local vernacular
whilst the proposal is seemingly not
being innovative in any particular way
is not considered to be tantamount to
alien built form in the vicinity which
is characterized by a broad range of
dwelling types now that simply isn't
true
the estates in brackendell is all
georgian style properties with
very very similar
windows and brickwork they are all
detached houses and not semi-detached
houses as stated in the report
so there's a fundamental flaw in in the
report i believe
and this property proposes
a rendered uh building
and a bungalow which is not in keeping
with the rest of the estate in
braggendell
so i would like to propose
or like to suggest that the committee
proposes a deferment on the basis that
essex county council need to be
queried as to whether they believed it
to be a two-bedroom
bungalow or a three-bedroom bungalow
has an adequate uh consultation period
been given to residents on the basis of
it being a three-bedroom bungalow and
not a two-bedroom bungalow as they
originally thought it would be
thank you for your time thank you very
much councillor cross council in newport
thank you very much
members have as any members would like
to discuss this please
consecrate a small one yep
condition six
provision of landscaping includes a
statement with indications of any to be
retained that is the existing tree
disruption so on
later in the report under paragraph
three four two
sorry what pages are we on please
112.
power 3.42
impact on trees
that already makes decision it seems it
says none of them to be retained so the
conditions
includes the possibility of
the
applicant identifying which will be
retained but the report itself said none
of them will be retained and i think to
be fair if you look at uh google earth
on the site there are four significant
trees but the car parking and the size
of the bungalow takes them out
anyway so i think the statement is
actually correct none of them will be
retweeted
but it's conflicting those two things
that he said
um
you're breaking this
breaking up the happy home claire would
you like to come back on that
please
yes so with regards to condition um
the soft landscaping thank you condition
six and it is a standard condition that
we impose regards to soft landscaping um
however i appreciate it 3.42 it does
make reference to the fact that um no uh
there's the suggestion that no um
tree shrugs will be retained but i think
it does it's really acknowledging the
fact that any that are to be removed
would not be of any real value so it's
not necessarily agreeing that they are
definitely to be removed it's basically
sort of saying that if any are to be
removed we're not overly concerned
because they don't have any great
immunity value and we will ensure that
we try to get a decent soft landscaping
scheme on the site by virtue of that
condition six for any that are removed
you can't put your hand down once i've
noticed you you don't you're not at
school i'm sorry
uh councillor fd just a quick question
claire
the um plans have they
changed on been on the portal they
changed so people could have looked and
as a two bedroom or three bedroom no so
i suppose just to clarify on that
particular point that was raised and it
was only the proposal description that
was inaccurate the actual plans
themselves haven't changed and they
still showed and still do now a
three-bed dwelling
and the design and access statement
refers to a three-bed running as well
within within that thank you thank you
stanley
thank you thank you chairman um
with with relevance to number 17 and
their
driveway
obviously that needs to be
cleared at all times
from any building traffic or anybody
working on that site
where
would they have an area where they would
use put vehicles on the site rather than
in the road
um i think that should be a condition
that no traffic should be left in the
road
as for parking or anything like that as
we've got a disabled party using that
i'm
pretty much
i'm concerned about the parking as it's
a three bed i know that we have a
regulation of parking
but i do think that we should consider
an extra parking bay somewhere on that
site whether it be to the
right hand side of those parking bays so
that you can get one on that corner to
make it a wrecked uh hexagon
type uh parking area rather than a
square parking area if that's possible
thank you
okay would you like to respond please
yes so in relation to um the actual
storage of materials and vehicles inside
which is a condition that we commonly um
get from county high rates as a
recommendation um on sites it's it's
more a condition that we consider is
reasonable and meets the tests to be
applied on much larger development sites
sites such as this um
people will generally be able to provide
their own it's quite a
reasonable size plot for this kind of
scale of development so there should be
sufficient space off
of the road to enable operatives
vehicles to be parked and materials to
be stored as well without the necessity
for a condition and so that's why in
this instance we've considered officers
considered we didn't think it was
necessary to impose that condition in
this particular case
um
with regards to
should i just come back on the parking
and then no i was just going to make
sure that you it does say about
contacting the police to take any lawful
action that to remove vehicles off the
road i think a condition because where
are you looking at cancer standing so
the rest of us can actually see what
you're doing
gosh you're asking me now
there is a
mention in the using the police to take
to remove vehicles from that
area i've ready
i've can't got it i haven't got it at
the moment i've moved on from that
but i did read
if the officer
knows what they've written um
there is something about the police
as it's not a
it's to do with highways 9.14.
good thank you very much
i'd like to make that
that as a condition that not to
you know even though i know it's a
highway thing but we have a disabled
person there that is not always
going to call the police and say can you
move that vehicle that sort of thing i
don't see as though that's an obstacle
at all i think that's what we can do i
think just to help the situation if
members had particular concern with
regards to that i think we could suggest
a recommended condition along the lines
of what county highways have actually
put at on that same page 9.14 and they
put a condition six about um areas
within curtis disciple purpose the
reception and storage of building
materials but we can also say um and
parking of operators vehicles as well
and so that's we can incorporate within
that condition that they've recommended
um on page 9.14.
i'll leave that's your discretion
thank you councillor foster
oh sorry um so with regards to the
parking at the moment there's two bays
actually shown now there is potential
for
a further thanks katie and there is
potential for a further bait to be
provided here um by just sort of
parallel parking in front and i don't
think it's necessary for us to actually
condition or acquire that when we have
required um parking spaces to be
provided but because they've got the
capacity and space to be able to do that
i don't think we need to get it actually
delineated on the ground as an actual
individual parking bay because they
clearly have capacity to be able to park
visitor parking their um
as and when and how in whatever
arrangement they sort of see fit there
is capacity on there to easily provide
that visitor parking bay
okay thank you thank you very much
councillor foster um thank you chairman
i agree with that condition i was going
to raise the same point second point is
the question really does this change the
footprint print from the plan that was
given outline approval in february 21
yes so it does differ to that and that's
why we're seeing a full application now
rather than reserved matters which is
what you more commonly get with an
outline application what's happened is
they've actually acquired a little bit
more
they've acquired a little bit more land
since the previous application so this
section here is an additional piece of
land that they've acquired and so
as a result they've now proposed a
slightly larger bungalow than that which
they were looking at outlined stage
having said that
all matters were reserved outline stage
so we weren't looking at overall
footprint or anything like that or
design or anything like that um but um
it's looking at a slightly larger
bungalow than what we saw then because
of that additional land
okay thank
you any other members
members we have a motion on the table to
approve have i got a second for that
make reference to that condition when
you are sort of making reference to the
approval of that so right that
additional condition that members wanted
if that's what they want so they're
voting on that as well yeah
so we've got for approval with the
condition we've got a second to done
councillor fd would you like to have the
condition the condition
re
said to yourself so you've got oh have
you got it written down i can read out
this will be so it would be
um
something along these lines i'd probably
phrase it a little bit better to be
honest areas within the cartilage of the
site for the purpose of the reception
and storage of building materials and
the siting of operatives vehicles
shall be identified should be submitted
to an agreed in writing with the local
planning authority clear of the highway
yep i've got knots of approval right
members can i
um
a show of hands for approval of this
application please
sorry extension right thank you so much
so members that is carried four
is seven
three against
two abstentions
thank you members that concludes the
meeting at
9 40. thank you very much members for a
good meeting
counselor stanley can i have a quick
word please